what was the hardest thing you've ever
walked away from
danica let's start with you
this is a little bit of a cop-out but um
i'm very decisive so i'm not really on
the fence when it comes to being done
with something
i don't think there's anything that i
think to myself like
oh man that was really difficult like
i'm decisive
and i make decisions easily and i'm
confident of my decisions
and i move forward and i'm just not one
of those when people ask
like what if you could go back and
change anything what would you change i
say nothing because everything led me to
hear so
i don't have regret so um
i i maybe look back and go like oh man
that was kind of a bummer and i
learned a lesson there but i don't look
back and think i wouldn't wish it
wouldn't have happened
got it i know that's a little bit of a
cop-out but i i just truly it's like
that that
mindset i have i'm fairly aggressive in
some of my thinking and actions as you
may know so you're intentional
so i don't have anything that i ever
really had
such perplexity i mean i took a little
time to decide to retire
but once i was ready to retire i was
ready i mean it was kind of a
sort of slow burn over 2017 season um
but then you asked me does there
anything about racing that i missed yeah
i know
i said how no and you're like well how
long did that take i'm like
it didn't take any was there a light
switch that it was like this is it i'm
done or was it
someone's conversation that got you to
finally see i think it was once i
once the my it was basically the quick
scenario is at the beginning of 2017
uh my primary sponsor had left and they
they pulled their sponsorship and so
um there was this thought of like oh my
gosh is the team gonna run me this year
what's gonna happen
and and they did and so the plan seed
got planted like what if you were done
and i actually had this good feeling in
my head of like oh i'm not ready to be
done because i've never really
loved racing i just loved aspects of
racing
so racing was my medium to certain
aspects if that makes sense
could be a cheap beat or no um no not at
all it was
um setting a joy setting a goal and
achieving it it was
um it was focus i really enjoy like
a very isolated focus like i have real
laser focus um so i
enjoyed that sort of like perfectionism
like can i stay in that focus
so well that i don't make mistakes um
and so i enjoyed that um that's awesome
yeah so racing was my medium for that
and so
um yeah anyway i i guess i the seed got
planted at the beginning of 2017 and
then so by the point in time where the
fall came i just really got to this
point where i was like i'm going to let
the universe decide for me
i didn't put any effort in but i didn't
say i didn't want to do it i was like
well if something transpires and the
sponsor comes along and everything works
out we move forward
if not we go away and it didn't so i was
like i'm done
and i remember the day that i told my
dad i was like you know i just and this
is a big day i was like i don't
i don't know i just said dad i was like
that's kind of the end i was like i
don't really
i don't really love racing and he goes i
know
he goes yeah yeah which was such a
moment for me i thought i'd disappoint
him
and he was like because i thought i'd
disa i'm like even saying it now i'm
like i feel like
yeah i cheated the system right like how
could you do that and do so well if you
didn't even love it it's like
well that's just not the full context of
what i loved i just loved aspects of it
and so
you know you can't tell me that someone
loves selling refrigerators they don't
they love the people skills they love
this
they they love chasing the cell they
love like negotiating they don't love
the fridge
right or maybe they do maybe
maybe they're fridge people maybe
they're not not
like but did you see this bridge
and i told him i was like i don't really
really love racing he's like i know you
were
you know you you were good at it and you
needed a job and i was like wow
that's true that's so interesting though
so when he said that were you like oh my
god relief
yeah wow yeah wow yeah it was
it was a relief it was a connection it
was a big deeper connection for us